it's a new year which means it's a new
chance to date a 10 to impress me on a
day-to note I don't know I guess you
have to ask questions so then you know
valley where my favorite first dates the
guy was mad at me because I'd never
tried del Taco
thank so we went to like the drive-thru
of Del Taco
and it was super cute you can make del
Taco romantic then you gotta think
I want like a veggie burger and fries
and a glass of wine and to talk about
politics with somebody
what's the best thing you say to me it
has to be something sunny has to make me
laugh one way or another it can be crude
it can be light-hearted it doesn't
matter to test me
my ideal first date would be for someone
to come and pick me up and and be like
you know I don't feel like going
anywhere and then I'd be like yeah
you're right let's not go anywhere and
then they'd be like no I kind of just
want to go home and watch a movie and
I'd be like all right I'll see you later
this is really fun
if you gained some new insight into the
world of hot women be sure to share this
video with a friend and head over to
Video GQ comm for endless amounts of
sexy ladies on the film